you
[Music]
so hello everyone my name is Thomas
Zimmerman I'm from the research and
software engineering group thank you so
much for coming today we can have a
presentation on boosting developer
productivity and it's going to be
presented by Thomas fritz
Thomas is a assistant professor at
University of Zurich in Switzerland and
he actually was visiting us over the
summer and he is also closely
collaborating with our group on
productivity and today is going to talk
about some of his work on biometric like
biosensors and productivity thank you so
much thank you so much for the
introduction and thank you all for
coming and thank you for listening to
this talk I'm really excited actually to
have this chance an opportunity to talk
to you a little bit about my research on
boosting developer productivity and how
we can use personal data to
revolutionize software development but
let me start out with my vision so my
big vision is really to make self to
developers more productive and happier
now you're all know no software
developer so you know that this is a
long long term goal to achieve and it's
not that easy but really what we want to
go is like if we want to better
understand stuff developers to help them
in the end to become more productive now
traditionally what we have done is
mostly in the research communities that
we've looked at what have developers
worked on what are the artifacts that
I've produced well as the code that I
produced or what have they done and
there's been some great research coming
out of that so there's been some great
research on for example mining software
repositories to then predict where the
bugs are and supports off the developers
and being productive okay now we want to
enhance this research and we want to
enhance that by better understanding
what does it really mean for software
developers to be productive so how do we
perceive their own productivity and also
to take advantage of persuasive
technologies such as self monitoring or
goal-setting to help them become more
productive so for the first part of this
talk I will talk a little bit about the
developer productivity research that
we've done in our group but then
afterwards I will also move on to a
different topic because to really get
soft developers to be more productive
and be happier we don't just need to
know what they've produced
but what they experiencing in their work
so what are they going through doing the
work what are difficulties that they're
having when they're programming or when
they're working on change tasks and
basically helping them by understanding
that better and so for the second part
of this talk I will talk to you about
the research that we've done on the
biometric sensing yeah
so I reviewed biometric sensors to
better understand what's going on the
cognitive and emotional states of South
developers to then support them and
being productive and then at the end I
will briefly also talk about one of the
projects we're taking advantage of the
insights that we've gathered in both of
them and that's what we call the focus
light and we've run a few study and
helped 450 people basically be more
productive
but let me start out with the developer
productivity now there has been a lot of
research actually looking at
productivity and understanding what
productivity means so for example what's
Humphrey has defined his personal
software development process where we
had software developers manually
tracking what they were working on the
time the tasks and so on and trying to
then help them to be more productive now
we want to enhance that by really also
getting a feeling of what does it mean
for software developers themselves to be
productive how did it perceive them self
productive and also taking advantage of
self monitoring approaches and other
persuasive technologies to make them or
to enhance their productivity in the end
so to get there we started out with
trying to understand how does it work in
the real world now you all might be
familiar with these activity tracking
devices here's the FuelBand that a
Fitbit that track your steps and as a
lot of people now 20 million people
approximately and projected a 60 million
in the next two years that were these
activity tracking devices and that's not
even counting the number of people that
have now the smartwatches or the phones
to track that daily steps and a daily
activity now with this proliferation of
these devices in the real world there is
really a chance for naturally studying
them or for studying the use of these
devices in the naturalistic scenario
over the long term so what we've done is
we've started out with an interview
based study where we had 30 people that
use these devices for more than three
three months and up to four years and we
interviewed them about the usage and
here's just some of the insights that we
gathered so one of them was that these
devices really motivate a durable change
so people even after four years still
stated that the use of device is looking
at the number of steps that they have
and trying to keep up 140,000 steps per
week park their cars for other way or
for example always took the the
staircase instead of the elevator up now
at the same time what we also noticed so
so basically that shows us that it
doesn't just motivate you to become more
active in the first place but it also
helps you to stay on a high level of
activity for long term at the same time
what we noticed is that these are our de
Wellness becomes extremely acute so
people really focus on this on these
metrics on the step count so as they
became more and more active they also
went to the to the gym and so on and
then they use different devices that
they have beforehand and for example
they used to treadmill and notice when
they honor the treadmill but the hill
climb
when they went backwards on those things
that the step count wouldn't that the
activity measuring device wouldn't count
it so it become very extreme and a basic
cut out these activities that wouldn't
help them to increase their count in the
end so we noticed here is we really
don't just need to understand like or
grasp a good metric in the beginning we
really you need to make sure that we
support the changes that they have by
becoming more active in the long term
now the question obviously is so this
was in the naturalistic use of activity
tracking devices but and how does it
help her self development and so for us
the question was what does it really
mean what are these steps that we have
forced off the developers is there any
number that we can use that we can just
pour over and show off to developers to
not just be productive but be more
productive and understand the products
really better and so do do so we
addressed a couple of questions so one
of them is what does it mean for as I
mentioned what does it mean for software
developers to be productive how to
develop us today measure and assess or
want to measure and assess their own
productivity and
how can we use that how to developers
improve their own productivity and how
can we use the insights to help them be
more productive now important thing to
mention here is when I talk about
productivity there's obviously a lot of
notions of productivity so there's this
notion of business value and the outcome
in this talk I really focus on the
person or the individual perception of
productivity of the software developers
because in the first up we want to help
them become a productive themselves so
provide them some self monitoring and
later on we might go into the other
directions too but for now it's really
the focus on this so to address these
questions we conducted a set of studies
and the first thing that we did is we
did a survey in which we tried to gain a
broad sense of what it means to be
productive of how they assess their own
productivity how to perceive their
productivity and we had a 379
participants big chunk of them was here
for Microsoft and another one was on a
public crash a survey that we had set up
and then we wanted to also understand
how does it look in the field like when
we observe them so we did in-depth
observations basically and rated them he
is sitting here one of my PhD students
on the left and he sat behind developers
logging every single action that they
did for two hour ever four hours of 11
participants in three different
companies and then finally we also
wanted to do that more long-term so we
developed a monitoring app that we
installed on developers machines and
where we tracked them in detail so there
was 20 developers that we had and we
tracked them for seven to 20 business
days basically on their computer and at
the same time we also asked them
periodically to log their own or to
report their own productivity so that we
can sort of assess run in a productive
and in a productive and so on and we had
20 participants from four different
companies and I won't go into more
detail on that one but we also have done
a follow-up study where we have now had
120 people actually that used these the
monitoring up for up to six weeks where
we've gathered more data and we're still
in the process of analyzing that but
here just to show you some of the
insights of that one when we asked
developers when they they perceive
themselves as productive they said well
I have a productive
workday when I compete a lot of tasks or
goals so when I make progress on the
tasks that I'm supposed to work on and
at the same time when I have very few
context switches and interruptions that
distract me from my work now there were
other things like having no meetings and
people were very had mixed feelings
about them some people consider meetings
very positive some people consider
meetings very negative but I really
differed based on the context of the
meeting on the setting of the meeting
how many people were in there and so on
oh well really what I what we found is
that it really makes the most import are
the most important thing is that people
complete and make progress on their
tasks and have very few contacts which
is very few disruptions or distractions
from their work now we also asked him to
assess their own productivity and what
we met a how they want to assess their
own productivity and we presented them
23 different metrics and what we found
is that there's one metric that most
developers are was the most prominent
one for all developers a most positive
one was the number of work items I
closed which is not surprising given
what we found just before but overall
based on the answers from the 380 people
after for the 23 metrics that we had
there was always it was always an
individual combination of the metrics
that somebody wanted to see to assess
their own productivity so really
differed by person what they thought was
most important to assess the
productivity of the day so there wasn't
one single best step metric in this cut
in this case now then we went on into
the field and try to observe them that's
why the second one the time I spent in
meetings is that you said there was
there different views about whether or
more time in meetings most productive
versus last yeah this doesn't this is
just a pure measure of it's not
suggesting whether it's positive or nay
yeah it's not like they see here we ask
them would you consider that as helpful
for you to assess your own productivity
when you see how much time okay
and to be fair might be just like that
some people don't have any links about
like mixed feelings some people think it
very productive so then they think it's
good or some people think is very
unproductive that's also good because
you see that you're unproductive mm-hmm
good question thank you and so then we
run over to us
observe them in the field and we get
captured a lot of data so just to break
that data down we categorize it into
different activities so we have the
different development activities version
control debugging coding and so on but
you also have other activities such as
the browsing related work related
information browsing work unrelated
information meetings and so on and
here's a here's a view of the training
of the 11 people so you can see the 11
people on the on the lap on the y-axis
from three different companies so that's
why the different letter in the first
place and here we captured them for two
hours so in total it was four hours but
and the time varies a little bit but you
did in two hour chunks and they paced
based on their availability but
sometimes a little more a little bit
less but overall you can see there's a
lot going on so let me just zoom in into
one of them so you see one of the
developers s1 and you can see the
developer does a lot of like based on
the categories that we classified them
into a lot of coding in the beginning
debugging at some point the person has a
meeting and then afterwards he or she
wrote and read a lot of documents or
worked on a document and also started
coding again so all there was a lot
going on there was 148 activity switches
and in the background you can also see
these different grades of shades of grey
these indicate the tasks that they were
working on so when the shade of grey
changes that's when they switch between
a task overall this developer was
working in four distinct tasks and
switching between these different tasks
27 times over the two hour time period
so of all there was a lot going on and
especially when you look back here it's
the same for pretty much everybody now
if you recall what we talked about
before and they said I'm particularly
productive in a very few context which
is very few tasks switches and so on so
then we were interested in finding out
the day a few particular productive and
indeed when we asked him most of them
felt very productive during the time
that we observed in and that is despite
the fact that he had so many tasks which
was like thirty and a half tasks which
is per hour and also very wave many
activity switches 47 per hour so
basically every minute a half or so they
were switching between a different
activity again
and when we interviewed them afterwards
we also found out that really depends on
the type of context which on the cost of
the context which so sometimes a context
which is not very expensive and to stop
and work on a and and as people noticed
here's like to stop and work on a
different task is a more costly context
which toon writing a quick email so
sometimes they started up a test
application and had to wait for the
application to actually run and when
they would switch back and forth between
email in their case it would actually
make them more productive rather than
less productive so sometimes it can be
beneficial to actually have context
which isn't really depends on the cost
of it and then some insights on what we
did afterwards as we money taught them
so we wanted to see for a long a period
in time so that was for two hour or four
hour time frames so we installed this
monitoring app on peoples computer and
here's just sort of the break up of the
work from these 20 people so as they're
all developers is not surprising that
they spent most of their time coding 21%
and they spent a lot of time an email or
browsing and when we looked at the
differences between companies and
between people we noticed that there's a
big change of big variety and how much
time they spend on each activity so
there was for example one company where
developers spent only less than a minute
per day on their email because they also
had in like a certain policy in the
company to use emails just for certain
and topics while others spent on
approximately 75 minutes per day on
email like handling the emails and so on
and again what we noticed is there's a
really high fragmentation of the work
that people experience other people have
when they're working so every three
0.322 minutes they would switch between
different activities and finally we also
looked at sort of like how did have
productive times change over the day and
over those two weeks we could basically
glasstor the developers that we had in
three different patterns so we had these
people that were more productive in the
morning and some people that were a lot
more productive in the evening so they
had this like low productivity in the
morning and then the bump of
productivity in the evening and some
people that were particularly
unproductive at lunchtime and what were
productive in the beginning or at the
end of the day so really it is a very
individual thing at a product
it depends on the developer one day like
their tendencies of productive times and
so on so just to summarize that what we
found out is that when we looked at
activity monitoring there we can really
supports of developers and becoming more
air support people in becoming more
active over a long period of time so
question is how do we bring that over at
this point there's no single best step
metric because it's always an in
combination of or an individual
combination of different metrics that
helps off to develop us to assess their
own productivity but overall what we've
found is it's really about making
progress on your tasks and reducing
these costly contexts which just as
people have I have now this really
caught a causes or poses the question
basically how do we measure the cost of
a context which how doing whether when
people are very focused for example and
not so focused well traditionally what
we've done in the past is they really
looked at asking people to manually
write down what are you working on or
what are you doing during your work but
that's becomes really feet alike
infeasible and when you strips off
between the different activities between
the different tasks more recently Toyota
has envisioned this framework for
software developers to have already
certain sensors installed and measure
all of the things about the software
developer but yeah as you can imagine it
becomes very difficult to be productive
in this environment especially because
you have cold feet and whatnot now today
there's a huge opportunity because we
have a lot more sensors available that
are a lot less invasive and it can help
us tell us something about the developer
and about the cognitive and emotional
states of the software developer and so
now research we want to take advantage
of these sensors and really better
understand what's going on inside of a
software developer but all of these
devices have based on is this link
between the physiological states or the
physiological features and the
psychological states so for example
there was research that found that the
higher a mental load the the slower the
blink rate of the is and as well that
the higher the pupil dilation is so you
can basically measure
physiological features of the person by
better and better understand what's
going on inside and he can imagine
preparing for this talk I might have
been a little bit stressed in and I
start sweating a little bit more and he
can again measure the sweat to see
something about the stress now the
question that we have is can we poor use
that in the software development domain
to make softer developers more
productive and better understand what's
going on in there so the basic question
that we had is can we measure developers
cognitive and emotional states to
support them in network now if we're
able to do that um we might be able to
actually prevent mistakes at the time
when they're being created or at before
they created and before I committed to
the repository and we factored also
cognitive difficult parts of the code so
if we know when people experience
difficulties working on certain code
elements we can basically help them
interrupt them for example so just
taking a break or I suggest somebody
else to read over the code and perform a
code review because this was
particularly difficult to to change in
the code for example at the same time we
might be able to measure the focus on
the progress that developers have and
that again can feed back into the
self-monitoring that I was talking about
beforehand where we can give them a
better sense of how productive how
focused about during their work and then
finally we might also be able to reduce
these costly interruptions these costly
contexts which especially like for
example in-person interactions by other
people at inopportune moments so when
you're particularly focused on your task
and it's particularly expensive to get
out of the task now to do so our version
is sort of like that we want to in a
long term prevent bugs so basically step
in before the bug is cumulative
repository and also reduce costly
interruptions and for that I'll talk
about three questions that we addressed
in the in the recent past one of them
was can we use biometric sensors or
readings from biometric sensors to
predict the difficulty of tasks or
whether or not a task is easier
difficult can we use the biometric
sensors also in the field of a longer
period of time to predict code quality
concerns
so the the quality concerns that others
have raised in code reviews and I can we
also use the biometric sensors to
predict when patty when interruptions
are particularly expensive or not for
all of these approaches are following
these questions we used a similar
approach in the background so we did as
we used multiple biometric sensors so
you can see the nearest guide mine band
to measure brainwave activity and that
allows us to capture brainwave bands
such as Alpha Beta Gamma Delta Theta
wave stead people our researchers have
previously especially in psychology have
previously found and attributed to
aspects such as visual attention mental
workload and so on at the same time we
also used electrodermal activity sensors
which are wristbands and I could tell
you something about the tonic and the
phasic signal and they can again be
related or were correlated to general
state of arousal and a surprise in
literature before and I finally we often
also used an eye tracker and the eye
tracker is interesting because it
doesn't just tell you where people are
looking at is better specifically but it
can also tell you about the pupil
dilation so you get the exact location
where they're looking at and at the same
time sort of under pupil dilation you
can say something again about the
cognitive load when we did these studies
what we had as we started out with
several participants that use these
sensors um and then we recorded the data
either in the lab or in the field and
based on what the study was set out to
do we cleaned the data so there's a lot
of noise filtering that you have to be
there and you have to do you have to
filter out invalid data as well then we
use the sliding time run approach so
understanding or assessing or using
certain windows of time off the
biometric data to to capture their state
and then extract the features from the
biometric data and in the end train a
machine learning classifier didn't see
if we can predict aspects such as
developers perceived difficulty or the
interrupt ability based on the captured
data and the features that we used in
this case so let me start out with the
sensing of the tasks difficulty that was
the first study that we did and we were
really want
the first to actually do that in the
field of software development and I was
worth researchers here at Microsoft
Annie bagel particular and what we had
is we had 15 professional software
developers come in here in a controlled
lab environment so a control lab
experiment and we had eight small code
comprehension tasks that were about one
to eight minute long and we varied these
tasks based our attitude to stress
different skills so math and logic
skills working memory but also spatial
relations and so here you can see the
setup we had the 15 developers and you
can see the 8 different tasks these
tasks that's where the geometric shapes
these tasks were mostly either to ask
him about whether or not two rectangles
overlap or in which order three or four
geometric shapes were drawn and then we
assigned the task order to them randomly
to mitigate any any learning effects and
then what we have to do when you use
biometric sensors you also have to sort
of gather or capture a baseline so
between every task we actually would
show them or show them a two-minute
fishtank movie where I just looked at
the fish tank and the first memory was
used to have to have them calm down and
a second manner was used to capture
their baseline so that we could compared
against the task afterwards that they
were working on for this study we used
three biometric sensors we use the the
brainwave band we used two electrodermal
activity wristband and we used an eye
tracker and we captured multiple
different features with these sensors so
here for example you can see for the eye
tracking we used the number of vexations
the number of saccades from the eda we
used the number of facing Peaks per
minute and from the EEG we captured
these different or extracted features
such as the different brain wave bands
alphabetical to gamma but also certain
illnesses that have previously been
linked to things like the task
engagement so better divided by alpha
plus theta for example and I what we did
as we trained our we we also had
developers rate difficulty off the task
so how the figure was a task we captured
how long it it took them to complete
this task and we also had them answer a
NASA task load index survey so that we
could capture knee and how difficult a
task for us as well and I'm finally we
don't train in a face learning
classifier
I'm using k-fold cross-validation so you
can see for example the one time where
we trained it on seven tasks and then
try to predict the eighth task we also
did the other way around trying to
predict learn on 14 people and
predicting on the 15th person who and so
on to see how good we can actually use
classifies train on other people for
another person or where if you've seen
everybody basically predicting for a
different task that we haven't seen
before hand and one of the major
outcomes was really that this biometric
data can really help us to accurately
predict the task difficulty so whether
or not a task is easy or difficult now
that's one of the major things that were
interested in here is because it was the
first study and as obviously a lot of
things that we can still improve based
on the usage of the biometric sensors
and also how we captured in the
filtering of the data afterwards the
cleaning of the data but it was really
an initial or the first study in that
field that showed us that it is useful
and valuable to use these biometric
sensors and he can also see when we look
at the different kinds of sensors or
combinations of sensors that the use of
all three sensors the eye tracking EDA
and EEG was the best but even just using
the eye tracker app from fairly well in
that case so this was sort of like a
very controlled lab experiment where we
looked at people coming in here sitting
in a sterile environment and the
question is can we do that out in the
field so what we did now is we wanted to
do or we ran a field study and we had 10
professional developers and we had them
work as per usual owner normal tasks on
a normal change task and in this case we
use two biometric sensors so we used a
wristband and we used a chest strap we
could use an eye tracking because there
was too invasive and we didn't have
enough eye trackers as well to set them
up but basically we had them used at for
two weeks so on average 11.6 days or
workdays per developer and we captured
their biometrics but we also captured
traditional metrics because he the ideas
to really look into can we predict these
code quality concerns so code quality
concerns being the things that people
mentioned in peer code reviews such as a
bug in the code such as not enough
documentation or
things that are difficult to read
understand and so on so we captured
these pica reviews and biometrics but we
also want to see if we can use these
traditional approaches something like
code metric cyclomatic complexity or
interaction metrics or change metrics
that have previously been used to
predict bugs in the code and to adapt
arcs in a repository and in the end as I
said we captured these peer code reviews
but at the same time we also captured
periodically the difficulty that people
had working on certain code elements and
here's just a little bit of the how it
worked so people worked for two weeks on
average we had them have these centers
all the time like basically we came in
there in the morning had them were like
make sure that they were it and captured
or used to download data in the evening
as well periodically every 90 minutes so
we had something installed into the
integrated development environment that
would ask them about the elements that
were just recently working with how
difficult they rated them we would also
ask them when they committed any change
to the repository how difficult some of
the elements were so busy random
selection of these elements and then at
the end whenever somebody Pico reviewed
the code commits we also captured the
quality concerns that people had in
there and so just to say at the same
time we also so we captured the
biometrics over these over the period of
two weeks but we also always captured
the code metrics for each code element
that they worked with at the time that
they were working with the interaction
metrics as well as the change metrics
and the outcome here was that in the
field the biometric data really
outperformed the other traditional
metrics in three out of four cases so
for predicting difficulty what you can
see here is the biometric is the purple
one and the traditional one here on the
left and so basically does better than
the other ones and when you combine the
two you also see that that's even better
so basically biometrics really add
additional value and additional
information to predict how difficulty a
coded how difficult a code element is so
this was for predicting code difficulty
and at the same time we wanted to look
at how is it to predict really these
quality concerns to pee
raised in the peer code reviews and what
we had here is that again the biometrics
did the best overall the results are not
amazing in a sense that obviously it's
like that's like you see the bald one
shows you which one was the best for
predicting quality concerns or no
quality concern and wild biometrics are
the best they're still not perfect but
you have to remember in this case again
and that's the first time that somebody
used it for biometric sensors for two
weeks in the field and I wasn't
obviously there's a lot to be learned on
how we use these sensors how we clean
the data and so on and so forth but
interestingly it was from there so you
can see the code quality concerns and
our overall in the 580 reviewed classes
where the committed changes to there was
about 95 had a quality concerns and some
of these were bugs some of these were
missing test cases but also insufficient
exception handling SH and other things
that we could predict in the end so
basically what I've shown you now is we
had these two questions can we use
biometrics to predict task difficulty
can we use them to predict the code
quality concerns and we really found
that we can do so
in the lab as well as in the field and
that can help us with our long-term goal
to prevent bugs because by knowing when
they're having difficulty we might be
able to intervene before they're
committing it to the repository or else
you also and prioritize code reviews but
let me pause you right here let me give
you a short pause here just to regain
some energy so basically this
interruption isn't so bad because I
might actually also regain your
attention
so sometimes interruptions are bad
sometimes interruptions are good and so
for the last talk I will talk about for
the last part of this talk I'll talk
about interruptions and when we try to
look at capturing whether or not people
are interruptible what the cost of
interruptions are and also how we can
help them to reduce the interruptions so
for this one we did a similar study as
before but in this case we had a lab in
a few study for the lab study we had
eight graduate students and we had these
lab students for work on three different
change tasks and we used two biometric
sensors and then we had them way to
interrupt ability at random points in
time for the field study we had temper
the developers and we had them work as
per usual for two hours in the field
under normal tasks and again we used two
biometric sensors and we had them ready
to interrupt ability not in a way that
it looked like in the field he is one of
the developers our participants that of
our study and he can see that the normal
work setup that they have but in
addition we had them wear the wristband
sensor which was the category three for
capturing the electrodermal activity and
we had them were the nearest guy mind
band to capture del eg data and at the
same time we also set up this tablet on
the right side on the left side of the
developer that would trigger these
random interruptions and the way they
would look like is the first place there
were basically make a sound and tell you
okay here's an interruption then the
person clicked on start they got an
arithmetic exercise algorithmic exercise
to basically extract them from their
previous tasks that they had and we
asked them to rate the interrupt ability
so interrupt ability but also the
disturbance and the mental load so we
captured these ratings and also other
things that I won't go into more detail
here but the resumption and -
interruption acts and so on and in the
end the findings were again that these
biometric sensors can be used in the lab
as well as in the field to predict the
interrupts ability of the software
developers so interestingly especially
in that in the - case day we were pretty
good at predicting the interrupts
ability of the developers and improving
over the majority classifier and but in
the four the five cases where we try to
predict a very fine-grained dropped
ability of the developers it was still
working in the lab but in the field with
all the noise it was not didn't achieve
any any improvement anymore so just to
come back to the third question is like
okay so can we use the biometrics to
predict interrupt ability based on a lab
and a few study we were able to show
that we can do so especially in the in
the 2k state when we try to do it very
fine-grained and we obviously need some
improvement still now the question that
you might ask at this point is well this
is all nice but how do you ever use that
in the field or what what can you do
with that in the field so we yes
absolutely just first uh da or the first
study you talking about elizy
improvement over the majority classifier
did you find one so for this one for the
first study in the control environment
oh yeah it's an improvement so we had
80% accuracy in the in the and a
majority classifier would predict 56 so
it's like the improvement
I can't calculate might happen there was
was an improvement thank you at all good
so how do we use this in the field now
and so here's one of the studies that we
did now which is a field study where we
tried to really reduce the interruptions
that people have so we call this the
focus light and what we did here is we
designed this light
it's basically a USB board and with an
LED light and we put a ping-pong ball on
top of that and we were changed the
color of that ping-pong ball so either
in three different states so we had
available so would being green we had
busy when it was red and we had do not
disturb and was red blinking basically
similar to the Skype status that you
know or the link status that you know
and we calculated the interrupts ability
at this point and based on the computer
interaction of people had and would then
update the status of the light as well
as the status of the skype so that
people would externally be available
aware of what is the state of interrupts
ability of that person we improved that
over the time because that became two
weeks because we had a lot of people to
participate in the study and was too
expensive to actually produced him all
the time so then we used these LED
lights sometimes we also put a ping-pong
ball over those ones as well but
basically what we had in the end is we
had phone at forty nine participants or
knowledge workers that had that we set
up with these sensors from 12 different
countries and 15 locations from one big
company ABB in this case this is one of
the field offices that we had where we
tried it out I was in India and we had
the whole office or the whole team set
up with these lights
obviously enlarged the the color of the
lights but we really went to all of
these places set it up where the people
and then collect the data from these
people what we did is we had them work
as per usual so we didn't basically do
any any specific thing but we had we
asked him afterwards when they used the
lights for a specific
period of time so more than five weeks
actually to answer a survey we had them
also 23 of them we had in-depth
interviews with them after two month of
using the light and we also had them
self-report the interruption logs and we
got 36 of those that that captured it so
he is sort of like the the timeline in
the beginning we installed the light in
the first week after installing
sorry we didn't install light in the
beginning we just installed the monitor
to monitor the interactions and so on
and for some of the people that actually
manually locked their interruptions we
captured the manual menu locked
interruptions in this week then we set
up the light we left the light there
standing for a week because there was
certain buyers when when the lights
where people would actually come over
and interrupt you more often because it
occurs about the light itself there were
interest is like what's going on here
why do you have a red light why don't I
have a red light and then talk about it
but and obviously in the week afterwards
then we against asked him in the post
install period to lock the interruptions
and and capture how many interruptions
they have per day and then I like lock
the interruptions when they had an
interruption actually and then at the
end after five weeks we had them we
mailed them a survey and after two month
approximately we asked him to are we
interviewed them in the field so he has
one of the outcomes and has multiple
outcomes obviously because we gathered a
lot where you gather these surveys two
interviews under logs but just from the
manual interruption logs we noticed that
there is a 49% lesser interruption or
there's 49 percent less interruptions
per person per day during these two
weeks where we captured before and after
and there was a significant reduction in
the number of interruptions to have
people had and people were also stating
that in the interviews and in this
survey that this really created an
awareness and even for a long time like
even after a two-month of the end like
when they had the interview people were
really still a lot more worried about
the cost of an interruption so if I go
over I shouldn't just ask him about my
weekend if they feel if they are very
focused but I should think about when is
the right time point in time to
interrupt them and so another thing
which was really positive for us is that
even after so we started out with one
month or five weeks of usage and we
wanted and it was basically the the
period of the study but people kept
using this device and where you can see
here is that
some point of November 2015 like we
started in July approximately by
November 2015 we started tracking when
they used the device of an ax plugged it
in when they used it and here you can
see that up to September 2016
seventy-five percent of the users were
still using this device on a daily basis
nowadays like geeks and that's because
in the middle there the the weekends all
over the weekend they didn't use the
device and on the top you can see the
different sites where we set it up so in
the beginning of run one of the biggest
sites in India and Norway Sweden with
num just some of the major sites that we
had set it up with so people really kept
using this device and there was more and
more questions if they if others can
also ever device people really liked the
device and even adapted it when they
didn't like the ping pong ball put up
their own little light and people who
didn't get the device also wanted to
have a light and sort of a is he some
created their own picture explaining
here for pics means that I'm busy or not
I'm showing other people and and
basically they were jealous of not
having the light so just to sum up all
of this is I wanted to show you my
research a little bit of some of the
research that we do trying to make self
developers more productive I talked a
little bit about how we can use
traditional enhance traditional we're
productivity research by really grasping
what it means for self developers to be
productive and also using self
monitoring and technologies or other
perserve technologies to make them a
productive and I've also talked a little
bit about the biometric sensing where we
try to better grasp what's going on
inside of a software developer what are
their cognitive emotional states and one
of the projects that we've done to
really bring this together and now where
we hope in the future to also use
biometric sensors to be better in terms
of the accuracy of the interrupts
ability algorithm now all of this can
really revolutionize the field and can
really help us to reduce costly
interruption it can also help us to
measure focus in progress that again
then can be used to to for self
monitoring and it can help us to prevent
bugs so not just predict bugs later on
but prevent them in their time at the
time when they might be created and we
fact our cognitive difficult parts of
the code now all of this research wasn't
just done by me but to a big extent by
my great PhD students and so these are
the PhD students
Villa Maria chuga cata kovitch and under
Amaya which he's seen here who has done
I've done a lot of the research
obviously but a lot of this research
wasn't just done by me and my PhD
students but also in collaboration with
people from Microsoft so Tom for example
Tom Sherman and Andy bagel but also in
other companies David Frum from ABB NL's
from the University and to big extent
also by the professional software
developers that worked with us on these
studies so we've worked with a lot of
different companies to set up or to run
these field studies so does the end of
my talk and I'm happy to take any
questions that he have yes three more
details thank you
did you do da thoughts or did you study
self-imposed interruptions for example
you know is there a declining point
where 100 you know uninterrupted time
loses its value like a plus of attention
span is there a rhythm where people may
want to interrupt themselves to refresh
it's a really good question and it's a
really really interesting and exciting
topic so for now we only studied the
external interruptions by other people
like or through Skype but research has
shown that like you have approximately
as many self interruptions as you have
external interruptions and that's sort
of where we want to go next because one
of the things that we also noticed that
people said themselves that the light
would help them to be motivated so when
they saw that the light was Green
they're like oh my god I'm not
productive so they actually tried to be
more productive
obviously it there that like the game
the system a little bit and try to be
red or when they sada started they were
red they try to keep it or maintain it
in the red and busy state because it
tell them okay I'm more productive but
obviously there is there's good and bad
things like sometimes you like there's
these techniques like Pomodoro Technique
where if you interrupt yourself every
try for 25 minutes and take a
five-minute work but it actually helps
you to be more productive afterwards and
that's something that we want to look at
in the future as well thank you
so I like the challenge if you have got
some gems of effort throughout the
Pelican so let me start with the one
that was there in the beginning which is
you know based on surveys and what
people think makes them productive or
not some product differences of this
collection contraption interruptions I
mean fundamentally rates of this a
survey based research right and so what
gives you confidence that their
perception of productivity is a
reflection of reality according to
somebody else and I don't you know that
we have subjective measures we can
probably take issue with any number of
them but you know in many areas they
pointed preferences or you know I just
like widely divergent no it's it's a
really good point so what is a good
measure of productivity I wanted to
point it out before and like what we
really focused on is perception of
productivity of the individual developer
because we want to help them to
self-monitor himself to improve
themselves and we didn't look at other
values like business value would be
something else how much do you produce
how many lines of code and so on it
would possibly be something else but we
really focused on on the individual
developer and trying to understand it
that doesn't mean that that holds for
every developer and as we saw in these
measures everybody has different ideas
of what it means for them to be
productive and I think that's like what
we found out in other studies too is is
it's a very individual matter what we
consider is productive or not productive
now obviously that doesn't help you to
sort of assess the team productivity and
I think there's a new step that has to
go in and see can we abstract from that
level and go one level up and see what
does it mean for the team to be
productive so for example one of the
things that obviously comes up is when
you're reducing interruption for one
person it might mean that the the team
is less productive overall and so
obviously we want to measure that as
well like how much does it hinder that
the lights fortunately didn't hinder
that too much and people actually
mention that because even if the light
is red people would if it's a high
priority interruption I would still
interrupt them but that's a different
thing so there's definitely like another
step of measuring productivity where we
want to get it and and but that's for a
future to do
10x developer writes a once person
productive day is another person well
waste in fact right so how does that all
I mean you mentioned individual
differences took PC but that kind of
range of individual differences anyway
do you see it so I think there's a huge
individual like there's a huge
difference like even just looking at
meetings so if you talk to managers they
find meetings particularly productive if
you talk to individual developers well
not not everybody ok so so let's say
what I'm saying is like there's very big
differences in how I consider that but
if I help each individual to be more
productive in their own ways and then
the way that they I hope that I helped
the whole team to be more productive
obviously if people have a completely
distorted way of what what productivity
means then I'm at a loss but I think
then like that's a channel of loss in
general I think different people's
notion of what it is not really quite it
there's quite a broad range at there and
so you're sort of feeling measuring
their own perception or the relative
perceptions of how they were yesterday
or the week before and there are a few
absolutes in this picture of anything
for us
so I mean I'm curious to see if at some
points obviously the longer we use it in
the field the more we also find out and
I'm curious if at some point you
something crystallizes that he can use
so for example you might be able to use
biometric sensors to say one of the
things that always came up with like how
how long was I focused during the day
and and that might be a good measure
that could be used across different
sites just just as an example I'm not
saying that that's the best one but
that's like more abstract and let's say
lines of code that I produce in a day
because somebody might create ten lines
of code somebody else might bigfix boxes
fix box and we've talked to them and I
use three days before I actually fixed
that one line of code and change that
and so there's obviously a huge
difference
I mean knowledge workers or anybody who
has to submit be in the flow sort of
load a bunch of context into their a
matter really focus and if they make
mistakes they're gonna be bugs whether
it's in a worksheet or a C program right
so I'm wondering sort of also like all
of the techniques a lot of the things
you're looking at seems to be fairly
general to a Productivity worker at a
workstation but are there things that
are attributes of the software
development process that are sort of
very unique or would you pull out or
will you say that this is generalizable
to like the knowledge worker working in
a conference so it's a good question so
I mean for the focus like for example we
had fun at fifty knowledge workers it
wasn't just sort of a mr. burr 30
percent of developers when we started
out we only had software developers
because we said we know when they earn
the ID even a debugging then a
particularly productive so we could sort
of like measure that and sort of set the
state more accurately but eventually
people said like oh can we also have
that can we also have that and then we
try to generalize it the algorithm
wasn't as accurate for everybody
obviously and and there's certain things
that have to be adapted to that and the
knowledge of of the particular workforce
like B it's off the developers let's say
beat salesperson and so on can help us
really to make that algorithm better and
make the like measure focus better so
there's first off the developers it's
easier for us because we have a very
good understanding of what did
mean being productive workers might
spend different times in different apps
the notion of the app in which they're
doing their core work versus an app
where they're getting information or
searching you could have these sort of
things that they would naturally very
last an overflow is relevant for
developers you see a person in Stack
Overflow you sort of know what they're
up to
right but you don't expect like maybe a
data scientist okay
so here's to you so some of these
definitely are or we hope that in the
future you might generalize them as well
for the biometric sensing on the other
hand some of the things obviously very
specific like measuring the code
difficulty that they experience and we
didn't just track the biometric sensors
but also the elements that were working
with correlating those ones it's very
specific to yourself to developers
contacts on Facebook whether somebody's
worked in an open office
yep there's a there's not much Studies
on this and yeah everyone's gone too far
yeah now it's super interesting and like
and people have mentioned it before and
obviously there was multiple approaches
before we set the focus like for example
in into place where people said well how
they try to reduce to interruptions and
I said however since we used before and
I will just close my door like turn off
the light so that nobody would know that
I'm in the office which is obviously not
always working when I do it for two
hours some people would actually put up
really big pylons on their desk so these
construction pilots to show other people
and they said that January open to the
open office have made it sometimes more
like there were a lot more interruptions
but for some people was also really
beneficial to sort of like be close to
their people and and just shout over and
talk to them it would be in the future
since we have so many people at some
point interesting to really analyze the
differences but we had just added and I
think the more get better data we gather
the more we can do run these analyses
and worked over the different
populations
first of all I really like the idea to
focus light and just like I think that's
a very concrete finding which says is
that like you can use this you know we
can
used to focus like people and people who
used it you know like this they used
greater than 7 percent I'm so that's
that's like you never good pertain
ability that's awesome
one of my questions is about your
measures to assess productivity
specifically the kind of a trend of
measures so you in the statistic Z game
where he expected just the mean value
for the star rating of that out of five
of like that measure so for instance the
number of work items I closed on that
slide and then you also gave the
standard deviation to them so I'm
wondering do you can you maybe talk
about this the data of all these
measures or these just to measure you
don't you you said you we have truly
three metrics of a talk like a ball like
the lines of code for example today
create a date at number of a key to work
at him study created I don't recall all
of them like then the paper and I should
should have some more in my hat but this
sort of like 23 the people that we
thought up came from the literature and
also followed before in that that might
make sense to measure your own
productivity and but turns out in the
end Erstad
there wasn't one Cleveland or something
where like you know like the step
this would be a good thing for my
activity he wasn't like the even the the
number of work items not everybody was
happy with that because I said really
depends on the difficulty of the work
item and so on and so in the end there
was most people have their own sort of
set of features or set of metrics that
would help them the best to understand
their productivity yes for this example
it seems like the number of work items
dominates the use the mean values
greater in standard deviation so so this
one was the most prominent one and the
other ones are really all the other ones
were a little bit less but all of them
around three three point three years old
so they were all very similar like the
the number of work items was the one
that stood out by having a higher mean
value than the others but the other ones
were all very very similar and I really
just dependent on the person did you
move Freddy did you see or look for any
clusters in sort of the two noted may be
personality types like extroverts love
meetings and
eight eruptions we didn't do that so far
yet okay very interesting is obviously
an interesting research question we've
thought about it Thomas thought about a
two thing there is like trying to figure
out the personality traits and how they
influence that and there's certain
personality traits obviously as you've
seen with the product really trends like
there's this morning people evening
people and so on and they might also
affect how you want to measure when you
want to be productive and so on so like
this is one like long dust it was like
people is he typing hours as a
productive uses I but I was talking to
the doctor of this documentary and I'm
so big just does not get so you might
mean I can say missus your or your team
personally use this like something I
think to attract yourselves right now so
so I make my students use it so and
rebuilt the the retrospection app and he
is using it monitors using it so
definitely we're using it and within the
team I have a MacBook it's only working
for Windows so I can't use it
unfortunately I might yeah I know I know
I might I will most likely switch in the
near future because I also wanted to set
up the focus light and so on but we also
use the biometric sensors on us and and
especially like the less invasive on G
of just starting it up to were these
chest wraps to sort of measure that over
long term and correlate it with other
things
[Music]
what's the end of the talk I guess when
he talked about the setup with the
magnetic sensors connected great so my
understanding is that that's for a
specific kind of straight-line task
right so there is what well exactly at
the desk there so sorry buried that
really based on the based on the study
so for the for the task difficulty it
was a control lab experiment and we gave
them these small tasks that I was
talking about a little bit back there
they were one to eight-minute ask
because it was sort of like the initial
control lab experiment for this code
colleague concerns we really had them
work for two weeks and we didn't enforce
anything they were just working on a
normal task we were just tracking the
code elements they were working with as
well as the biometric sensors so we had
them sort of like the monitor installed
on the IDE and and the sensor and so
there wasn't any limitation on task for
the interrupt ability we had a combined
lab and few study in a lab study we gave
them tasks so sort of like open source
github test and others performed before
on one project two different tasks I
don't I think for this one we used a hot
or possibly I'm not I don't recall the
detail like check how to a project the
Jayhawker open source project and then
we had used two tasks that were open
more that somebody fixed beforehand and
had them work on these tasks but we sort
of like try to in the end as like in the
field we had them again used their own
tasks so most of the time in the field
for the two hours they were really just
working on the normal tasks and we
didn't enforce anything
another one is a subjective but I mean I
think for most mid-career about
developers involved in some number of
projects so that the straight line
coding task is not quite an actually
good notion of their own productivity
because part of this and they get
interrupted is to unblock somebody in
another project or what happened and so
the aggregate amount of productivity
sort of that comes out of these
individual tasks and in the correlation
there is of this depressant but it's
a nonlinear fish absolutely so so you
know in a sense you know you want to
measure the gap aggregate output not
what happens in a sprint you want to
look at the matter absolutely so it's a
good it's a good point obviously like
they are artificial in a sense when we
did them in the lab but for not all of
them we measured productivity so the
productivity didn't come like in this
ones we try to predict at code quality
concerns we didn't look at the overall
productivity or the progress that they
made over those two weeks and for the
small tests we also didn't do that but
obviously we know that the artificial
tasks are not easily to to just
generalize to the field but I think
there was a first step and that's where
we went to the field afterwards and had
her for two hours but like just to
mention like in most in all of the three
we didn't measure productivity with a
biometric sensors we only measured how
interruptible were in the last case how
difficult was a task in the first case
and how much can we really predict the
difficulty of the code element or the
quality concerns that he creating in a
core element but it's true like
obviously as you mentioned before and I
think there's a really interesting part
about not just looking at smaller
productivity increments but looking at
the overall thing looking at other
measures like one of the things that
people really mention is like all candy
correlated to sort of like the business
where you create each week but then they
were like when we talk to them as well
it's like creating a feature doesn't
mean that's very productive because that
feature might be just right after so you
almost have to have this really long
term horizon like even after six months
or something where you can only at that
point assess whether or not this was a
productive period and time based on
business value so this is really
difficult for any of the studies that we
run at this point but it is really
interesting at some point when more
people are using biometric sensors and
we could for example track it for a
whole year and sort of see that in that
case just an example
okay
[Applause]